after seven long and at times dramatic
weeks in court it all came down to
today's closing argument in the johnny
depp versus amber heard trial welcome
everybody to entertainment tonight drugs
alcohol abuse self-harm just some of the
wild allegations and testimony we've
heard and now it's up to the jury to
decipher it all
mr depp knows that he can turn into a
monster
she came into this courtroom prepared to
give the performance of her life and she
gave it
to mr depp's world you don't leave mr
death
and if you do
he will start a campaign of global
humiliation against you
we ask you to give mr depp his life back
by telling the world that mr death is
not the abuser ms heard said he is
i think both sides did a phenomenal job
the one thing that i think heard's team
excelled in was the ability to make a
more general commentary on what domestic
abuse is
we ask ladies and gentlemen that you
hold mr death accountable for his
actions
thank you so much
amber seemed upbeat walking in today and
johnny he waved to fans outside and
commented about the growing crowd of
spectators it's been a multiplication
and as if the trial wasn't already
surreal enough phones started buzzing in
court warning of severe weather
there appears to be an amber alert but i
think we're okay
both teams guided jurors through the
evidence photos videos magazine covers
and audio recordings i did not hurt you
i did not punch you i was hitting you
you are such a baby there is an abuser
in this courtroom
but it is not mr deb
and there is a victim of domestic abuse
in this courtroom but it is not misheard
the case went to the jury at 2 57 pm
eastern time legal analyst julie
rendellman says there's a lot of
information for jurors to sift through
the judge has given them a laptop which
contains most of the evidence that
they're going to be considering and you
have to realize that the jury has to
come to a unanimous decision that is a
difficult task and so it may take quite
a lot of time for them to come together
um can i also mention that people have
traveled from as far as europe to be at
that trial every day it's wild
y'all go back to work